LET'S HEAR FROM LEBRON AFTER THE
GAME WITH RACHEL NICHOLS.
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR YOU TO
BE OFFICIALLY IN THE PLAYOFF
BRACKET WITH THIS KIND OF WIN
TONIGHT OVER THE TEAM THAT HAS
BEEN A HUGE RIVAL FOR YOU OVER
THE SECOND HALF OF YOUR CAREER?
>> GOING INTO THE POSTSEASON,
TWO OF THE HOTTEST TEAMS, WE
WERE WINNERS OF FIVE, THEY WERE
WINNERS OF SEVEN OR EIGHT.
BOTH PLAYING AT A HIGH LEVEL.
WE KNEW THEY WERE COMING TO OUR
FLOOR.
THEY HIT US IN THE MOUTH IN THE
FIRST HALF.
WE HAD TO RESPOND, AND WE DID ON
THE DEFENSIVE END AND GOT GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM GUYS OFF THE
BENCH.
WE ALL CHIPPED IN FOR THE WIN.
>> TALK ABOUT THE SHOT YOU HIT
WITH ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT.
THE THREE.
YOU DID NOT EVEN LOOK IN RHYTHM.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING AS THE
BALL LEFT YOUR HANDS?
>> I PUT IN A LOT OF WORK IN MY
GAME.
AFTER DRAYMOND -- THE FINGER TO
THE EYE, I WAS SEEING THREE
RIMS.
I JUST SHOT AT THE MIDDLE ONE.
I WAS ABLE TO -- I WAS ABLE TO
KNOCK IT DOWN.
>> WHEN IN DOUBT, GO FOR THE
MIDDLE RIM.
WHAT DID IT FEEL LIKE ON THE
FLOOR WHEN YOU TOOK THE HARD
FALL?
WERE YOU WORRIED YOU WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE IN THE GAME?
>> I HAVE BEEN THERE BEFORE.
I HAVE BEEN POKED IN THE EYE
BEFORE,  COLLISION LIKE THAT.
TRYING TO KEEP MY COMPOSURE.
WE HAVE A FEW DAYS UNTIL WE KNOW
WHEN WE WILL GO TO PHOENIX.
A BIG-TIME WIN FOR US.
I WAS NOT LEAVING THE FLOOR, NO
MATTER IF I HAD TO PUT A PIRATE
PATCH ON MY EYE.
I LOVE THIS TEAM, I LOVE TO
COMPETE.
>> ONE BIG RIVALRY DOWN, BUT YOU
HAVE ANOTHER WANT TO GO WITH AN
OLD FRIEND IN CHRIS PAUL.
YOU MENTIONED GOING TO PHOENIX
AND FACING THE SUNS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE MATCHUP
WILL BE LIKE?
>> THEY PLAYED EXTREMELY WELL
ALL YEAR.
THEY DESERVE TO HOST HOME COURT
IN THE FIRST ROUND.
CP PLAYED AT AN M.V.P. CALIBER
YEAR ALL YEAR.
BOOK.
AYTON HAS GROWN.
THEY HAVE GIVEN THEM THE
SUPPORTING CAST AROUND THEM.
WE KNOW WHAT WE WILL GET OUT OF
CHRIS PAUL.
WE KNOW HOW GREAT HE IS, HOW
GREAT BOOK IS.
UP-AND-COMING FROM AYTON.
BUT IT IS THE OTHER GUYS WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE WE KEY IN ON.
THEY HAVE BEEN PLAYING WELL ALL
YEAR.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE THE SECOND
BEST TEAM IN THE WEST.
KRISTEN: NOW WE ARE GOING TO
LEBRON JAMES AS HE ADDRESSES THE
MEDIA.
>> I PRACTICE ENOUGH, I WORK ON
MY GAME.
I WAS ABLE TO -- TO THE MAN
ABOVE, A LOT OF PRACTICE -- I
WAS ABLE TO DRAIN IT.
>> WE SAW THE RESPECT BETWEEN
YOU AND A.D. AND DRAYMOND AFTER
THE GAME.
WHAT DID IT TAKE IN THE SECOND
HALF FOR YOU GUYS TO MATCH UP
WITH A HAD BEEN PUTTING OUT TO
GET THE LEAD?
>> FIGHTING, THEY WERE READY TO
FIGHT.
WE TRIED TO GET INTO THE GAME.
IT HAS BEEN A WHILE SINCE IT HAS
BEEN POSTSEASON, SINCE WE HAD
ONE OF THOSE TYPES OF -- THOSE
ENERGY, EFFORT, EVERY POSSESSION
COUNT GAMES.
I FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN
PLAYING PLAYOFF BASKETBALL FOR
SOME TIME.
WE HAD TO CATCH UP TO THAT.
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE THE
FIGHT TO THEM AND MAKE A GAME
OUT OF IT.
>> THE PLAY IN TOURNAMENT, WE
ARE CLEAR ABOUT THAT, BUT THE
SPECTACLE OF WHAT IT MEANS
DRAWING FANS TO THE NBA, WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TONIGHT?
>> I TOLD YOU HOW I FELT WHEN I
WAS ASKED ABOUT IT.
A FEW DAYS AGO, I SAID I'M READY
TO GO.
THE CHIPS LAY WHERE THEY MAY.
WE SHOWED UP AND WE WERE READY
TO PLAY.
>> WHERE ARE YOU AT PHYSICALLY?
WHAT ALL HAPPENED ON THE PLAY
WHERE DRAYMOND FOULED YOU?
WAS IT ONLY THE EYE?
HOW DID YOU COME OUT OF THE GAME
IN REGARDS TO THAT PLAY AND YOUR
ANKLE?
>> I'M GOOD.
I TOLD YOU GUYS I WAS GOOD.
I'M GOOD.
THE MOST MINUTES I HAVE PLAYED
IN A LONG TIME, I DID NOT FEEL
ANYTHING.
DRAYMOND, EITHER THE FINGER OR
THUMB, WENT DIRECTLY INTO MY
EYE.
THAT IS WHY I WAS DOWN.
MAKING SURE I WAS OK, THAT I
WASN'T BLEEDING, THAT I COULD
SEE A LITTLE BIT TO FINISH THE
GAME.
>> CAN YOU TAKE US THROUGH THE
MOOD AT HALFTIME OF THIS GAME?
WHAT CHANGED FOR YOU GUYS EARLY
IN THE THIRD?
>> THEY PRETTY MUCH GOT ON OUR
ASS AT HALFTIME.
SMOOTH IS KEITH MORRIS.
THEY GOT ON US AND SHOWED US
WE'VE GOT TO PICK IT UP.
THEY BROUGHT THE FIGHT TO OUR
BUILDING, AND WE HAVE TO BRING
IT RIGHT BACK.
GUYS LIKE THAT, WE TOOK IT TO
HEART.
DID NOT TAKE IT PERSONAL.
WE TAKE IT WITH US.
AND WE IMPROVED.
>> I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO DO A
LOT OF RESEARCH ON PHOENIX
COMING UP.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR THE TOP TO
BE IN A SERIES WITH CHRIS AND GO
AGAINST HIM IN THE PLAYOFFS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN YOUR CAREER?
>> IT IS A BEAUTIFUL THING.
PLAYING THIS GAME SUCH A HIGH
LEVEL FOR A LONG TIME.
I'VE ALWAYS ROOTED FOR HIM, D.
WADE, MELO TO SUCCEED.
AN OPPORTUNITY AGAINST MELO A
FEW TIMES.
I NEVER PLAYED AGAINST D. WADE
IN THE POSTSEASON.
BUT A GREAT RUN IN MIAMI.
IT WILL BE COOL TO BE ON THE
SAME FLOOR AND COMPETING WITH
ONE OF THE MOST FIERCE
COMPETITORS THIS GAME HAS HAD.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE MATCHUP.
>> WE HAVE TIME FOR TOW MO --
TWO MORE.
>> WHAT IS UP, BRON?
YOU GUYS HAD CONTRIBUTIONS
TONIGHT, BUT CARUSO ALWAYS SEEMS
TO STEP INTO BIG GAMES.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT HIM THAT MAKES
HIM DO THAT?
>> JUST ATTENTION TO DETAIL.
JUST VERY SMART, KNOW WHAT WE
WANT TO DO.
ALWAYS IN THE RIGHT PLACE AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
HE'S -- HE JUST MAKES PLAYS.
SOMEWHERE IN THE BOX MORE, SOME
OF THEM DON'T, BUT TONIGHT HE
SHOWED UP IN THE BOX FOR ME.
PRETTY MUCH CARRIED US IN THE
FIRST HALF.
>> WHAT JUMPED OUT TO YOU ON HOW
YOU GUYS HAVE HANDLED THE
DIFFERENT FORMS OF ADVERSITY?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT MEANS
MOVING FORWARD IN THE PLAYOFFS?
>> ONLY TIME WILL TELL.
IT WAS GOOD TO GET THAT FIRST
PUNCH.
THEY SAY EVERYBODY -- MIKE TYSON
ALWAYS SAID EVERYBODY GOT A PLAN
UNTO YOU GET IN THE RING AND GET
PUNCHED.
SO WE DID THAT AND IT FELT GOOD.
IT FELT GREAT.
IT SETTLED US.
WASN'T COMFORTABLE, BUT SETTLED
US, AND WAS ABLE TO BRING THE
FIGHT TO THEM.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WHAT WILL BE
IN STORE FOR THE POSTSEASON.
WE GOT ONE POSTSEASON UNDER OUR
BELT.